well you want the characters to be
better than you so you can learn
something from them and if they're
much worse than you then you can learn
something from that too
[Music]
of course blank was the first film that
i actually made myself
i wrote the script and was a producer on
it we were working with uh joe roth at
the time
who had run disney so he was a great
friend to me and
to filmmakers and so it was a great time
the studios were still making weird
movies like that
that um probably would get made today so
i sort of wrote
the character and for myself and we
hired george armitage who had made a
film that i really liked
with another psychotic lead um miami
blues with alec baldwin and elite
al baldwin jennifer jason lee so i
thought he understood the tone that we
were going that i was going for
and then we wrote parts for alan arkin
and dan aykroyd and minnie driver
it was a good time so that was a the
first kind of
film that i produced when i started to
become a kind of
filmmaker what i would do is i'd get the
script sort of
70 80 percent done and then i would know
that you're going to have all these
great actors coming in they're going to
have great ideas so
dan aykroyd's going to come in and you
know he's improvisational genius so
he'll come in with
you know stuff from the book of
revelations and crazy
stuff hey mental telepathy asphalt
projection
here you are right what do you want so
you want to kind of get the
script sort of pregnant but not fully
you know
not fully done and then just sort of let
the actors finish it they all came in
and
had things that they wanted to do and i
was
happy to you know alan arkin came in and
said
let's let's uh let's rewrite the scene
before we shoot and some of the other
producers like they were worried i was
like don't worry
that's alan arkin anything he's gonna do
is gonna make this thing even better
whatever level it's at it's gonna go up
two or three levels don't kill anybody
for a few days see what it feels like
i'll give it a shot no no don't give it
a shot don't shoot anything
oh and so then you would just
incorporate all this stuff in and when i
started making films i didn't have to
worry about offending the writer if i
was the writer i just wanted to be open
especially in a comedy things that
happened on the set and things that
happened in the moment
and surprises and accidents so it's
really just sort of
not only being open to those things but
actually cultivating them
obviously we didn't know i didn't know
who would um play debbie but when as
soon as minnie came in to audition
we that just seemed right so we knew
that right away and then
from that point on we started sort of
tailoring around her i had a feeling we
would get
alan to do it when he said yes that i
knew that that you know so
i was writing it to try to get him at
least interested enough to
come play and work on it a bit dan
aykroyd the same thing i just knew that
you just better buckle up and the best
thing with those actors is that you
um you end up getting run over you know
by a cement truck on screen
and then you want to make sure that the
camera's rolling and so like that's what
happens with my sister's she just
basically
runs you over with a cement truck and
you want to make sure you're filming for
it
ryan's life had been he was sort of like
he was in a kind of a musical arms race
with the beatles where
john lennon paul mccartney harrison
ringo starr
and those great producers were creating
these sounds and there was brian writing
from all the beach boys with one ear
from about 18 to 26 he was
either making a film making an album
they were on tv
and then he really sort of went away and
sort of went into a bit of an abyss for
a while when he emerged from that
15 years later that part of his life
wasn't
chronicled or filmed or you know it was
it was secret so
i was very lucky that brian and melinda
gave me access to them you know let me
ask a lot of questions let me hang out
with him and
try to find out what that was like for
him going into that dark place and then
coming out of it and also just trying to
have a sense of
you know getting a sense of who he who
he really is
an incredible combination of things he's
uh the most
vulnerable sensitive person you could
ever meet like almost like a heart with
two
legs but then he's also like very tough
like really tough and really committed
to his
to his art and what he wants to do and
really really tough so he's like
this strange combination of things where
you know it's almost like
water and steel and he's a kind of a
wizard and a bit of a magician
in so many ways like when he's talking
to you he'll talk to you and
sort of look above your head like he's
seeing colors or something i don't even
know what he sees but uh
he's definitely a heavy kind of cat in a
lot of ways
he said he was happy with it which was
which made me really happy
are these your shoes what yeah yeah
they're my shoes i didn't want to
you know mess up the car because i
jogged see i had jon on the beach
and i get sand in my shoes you know
ah so well that's very considerate but
you know i also get sand in my socks and
i had holes in my socks so i did make a
mess
anyway so i'm sorry about that what are
you going to do
[Music]
the project came about because i made
gross point blank at disney with joe
roth and kathy nelson
and then kathy called joe and said you
know we had this high fidelity
cross project and he said uh why don't
you get john to write that or adapt that
and so
joe and kathy called me and they said
what do you think of this book and i
love the book
i said oh yeah i could do that and i i
read the book and i thought um
that i could adapt it for chicago
because the only difference really was
when i was growing up we were obsessed
with like english
like the punk the new wave stuff and
in the book they were obsessed with
wilson pickett and
um solomon burke and all those kinds of
sounds but besides that and the accents
it was the same guys and it was the same
kind of story about male insecurity and
insanity so
i knew the record store where i grew up
and i knew those guys
and i i knew everybody just you just
have to take away the british accents
i thought of uh sending it to stephen
friers who i'd worked with and uh he
liked the idea and then they came
forward to to do with us i sort of had a
little secret
um secret information because i've
worked with tim robbins a lot and he had
an
acting company in la that did a lot of
cool radical theater called the actors
gang and i've worked with them
and so during some of those midnight
shows i'd seen jack play with his band
tenacious d
and he hadn't really had that great
breakout role yet but i knew how
talented he was and i knew what a great
musician and singer he was and hilarious
he was so in the book when jack's
character finally
uh plays at the end and kills it i knew
jack was the
as soon as i was writing i knew jack
should be barry jack didn't know that
but so i had to convince him but i think
he thought maybe me and stephen were
scary at first
we might be like scary people but then i
was like no no we're nice we're nice
so i think he was he might have been a
little bit spooked by like
stephen costino he's this british guy he
just sort of looks over you and studies
you and he's
super intense and so i said don't worry
about him finally jack said yes but i i
knew it was perfect
and i knew that i knew what the rest of
the world didn't know which was that
jack was a brilliant comedian and a
brilliant musician i knew that he would
just sort of that part would just
explode just happy for him such a great
guy
just a great actor
[Music]
that was a cool weird one because i i
was at an agency in la at the time
i remember saying to them i want to know
like what's your like the most
unproducible weirdest
script like you guys have all have a
black box or the red book or whatever
those things are where it's like the
scripts that can never get made
and they say well there's these things i
go no i mean like what is the
you know the most unproducible script
you have i want to know like what's
your your jewel of kryptonite for
commerciality
you know that what is that like i know
you guys have it somewhere
in your vaults right and he goes well
you mean being john mouse i said what
and then yeah and literally i found the
script there and i said to them okay
here's the deal because i read the
script and it was insane so i said
i want to be first in the door to the
financier whenever this gets if this
ever gets made and if you guys
do that i'll stay with you like indiana
jones like i found this
you know i've gone to the jungles and
found this rare treasure
it was just good it was it was like kind
of being in a
you know walk of fun house all the time
and so i do remember they had a
chiropractor on set because by the end
of the day everybody was all
twisted so everybody get cracked at the
end of the day
charlie's script was so brilliant that
um it was kind of perfect tonally but
you know even within that there were
still things that
you'd come up with on the day and like i
remembered the character in the
film that malkovich is friends with was
in the script it was kevin bacon and so
john malkovich and i were talking and
then we said the guy you should really
get
is charlie sheen john just started
laughing at the idea that you know
in his great hour of need he would call
charlie sheen to come over and confide
in so there's there was still
some give and take in in that way it was
great fun to to make that film
very fun
i'd seen john sales mate one and brother
from another planet he was a
guy that i admired a lot so i heard
about the project and
he wanted to meet me and he offered me
the role of buck weaver
and i knew a lot about the black sox
history and i knew about
i'd grown up going to the wrigley field
and the old comiskey park so
um and the old commission park was where
they act the black sox had actually
played so i knew all about the history
so i was very excited to do it
excited to work with john i mean i was a
big baseball fan and i was also um
you know i'd seen a lot of the bang the
drums slowly and some of the other
fear strikes out but there hadn't been a
really good modern baseball film and
then i thought
this could be really really great
immediately i read the
elliot hazenoff book which is a real
page turner
and then you just go back and would read
about the
letters that weber wrote and there's
footage and there's
there's archives of him and um you know
he just tried to
capture the spirit of him
[Music]
roland emerick asked me to do it and i
read the script
and i thought it was pretty wild and
outrageous and
i knew it would be sort of a huge movie
but i really liked um
roland he was a really great guy to work
with very collaborative and
very interested in your opinion about
things and how you can make it better so
it's always interesting working with
people like that and um
what i thought was interesting about him
as well is that the sets and the scope
of the thing were so complex but he
managed it so
effortlessly so he would have huge sets
with
you know cars and trucks and boulders
and all that stuff
but then in the back the set would be a
green screen so it wasn't all green
screen
which is people in front of the green
screen it was a mixture of sets with
green screen
and then you would have three or four
different cameras and but he would
manage to do these things every day like
he'd have an entire city block that
would be on
a moving machine or a shaking machine so
you'd have a limousine driving on a city
block and used
a white picking fence and you'd see four
houses and it would all be shaking like
it was an earthquake and you know
somebody had to make that in vancouver
a football field worth of you know
movable
stuff that can do that and it seemed
like every day you'd come on and there'd
be another
massive major contraption that he would
just be like all right let's go
and he would have it all sorted out um
so just technically kind of an amazing
brilliant kind of filmmaker that way
he would say um you know he'd say like i
think today you know you're getting out
of this thing and you're running and
there's this huge ash cloud and it's the
size of like
las vegas and you're running it i think
you're really scared i
got it so you did a lot of harrison ford
like running away from things
[Music]
that was interesting it was a sony thing
i did a couple things for sony and i
think john kelly was uh running the
studio then it was a great another great
executive
and james mangold had the project and
he asked me to do it and the whole thing
sort of centered on
the reveal at the end of the third act
and if you sort of
had disguised it well enough it would
really be shocking and so
it's kind of fun to have everything to
be on a tightrope where you know if you
if you screw it up at all and the
audience knows what's going on the
movie's dead but
um we i think we seem to manage to pull
it off i was very excited to work with
ray leota
who i always admire i think also like
when you're um
if you're doing a thriller or kind of a
psychological thriller you know
you sort of withhold information about
the characters
and so people are leaning into it a
little bit so
it's a yeah it's a little bit more of an
austere thing where you
you you're playing silences and are
working with the ambiguity that people
don't know
who the person is and so it was it was
more of a uh
kind of a straight leading man role with
a twist because as as it went on
you realize that people weren't who they
assumed to be
[Music]
that was a strange one when i was in
high school i was a big fan of jim
thompson and i remember
jim thompson made the um the cooper film
the killing
i was a huge fan of jim thompson stuff
and i tried to option
the book as a kid because i thought i'd
love to play roy dylan
i thought the whole thing with the
mother and the edible
kind of theme there was very intense and
cool and twisted
and then as i got older um i found out
they were going to make the film and
stephen freers was going to make it and
i think i'd made say anything a few
years before so
i was a little bit hot in the business
at the time so he met me and just sort
of walked around
and stared at me and then asked me to do
it i always loved the
movies about the khan and grift
so it was great to do that and to to
work with that kind of source material
which is
as good as it gets to work with angelica
houston
um let benning stephen fears it was uh i
was i felt like jack
i was like oh boy i'm with big boys now
i'm scared
i think the dostoevsky core at the
beginning that you can know all you need
to know about a civilization by um
looking at its prisons
so i added that to the to the
proceedings
but then it was a it was such a crazy
kind of whacked out cartoon
um that i thought all these people on
the plane are so eccentric and crazy so
i said what can i do so i thought
well what i'll do is i'll play i'll be
the first non-biblical
action star you know charlton heston did
a lot of stuff
like with no shirt and sandals but i've
never seen a modern movie with a
action star wearing sandals so i wore
birkenstocks and that was sort of the
extent of my thinking on that one once i
had the sandals i think everything was
came from there
[Music]
when i did 1408 i love being in that
steven king
um mindset he doesn't get the credit as
a writer that he deserves because he
draws you know that was a i don't think
it was 20 page short story but it filled
up two and a half hours and it could
have felt
up four hours it was like it was like
walking into doctor who's telephone
booth and
you see this small little thing but it's
just got way more space in there than
you think
that's sort of the way his writing is
but it came about and i read it and i
thought it was really interesting and i
just thought
it had that feel that you know identity
had where it was like a
supernatural psychological thriller or
even like in that being john malkovich
where questions like where what ground
you actually are i love that
sort of that element more than just sort
of the jump scares of the gore
i like the that rod sterling kind of
psychological
supernatural horror
it was a thing where i was sitting it
and this happens sometimes you know you
just get a phone call
somebody will say uh do you want to come
to china and do like an action movie
with jackie chan you're like
excuse me what you know uh yeah
that just sounds like way too crazy an
adventure to pass up of course i'm gonna
go do that and this was sort of like
that uh gillian flynn had
reconceived this show utopia and she
wanted to shoot in chicago
so i was like wow that sounds great and
then she sent me the scripts and i read
them all
i read them until four in the morning
because they were i couldn't i couldn't
put it down
it was just great writing and very
provocative and
shocking i thought this could be good so
i think this character uh
was in a way kind of captain of industry
he's what is marketed
these days as one of the great
benevolent billionaires you know
who are just there working for all of
our
safety and our future glorious unified
multiracial democratic green new world
that we're all moving towards so it's
set up that way
and then as usual with gillian however
you think you've pegged it
first gonna drop out and it's gonna drop
out another six times after that
to me it was a good take on this idea
change coming from the apex of power
down you know from the one percent of
the one percent down it was a good
twisted take